sua mãe estava aqui agora a gravar e
vejam aquela médico olha só essa
aranha eu vim aqui está o rio guaíba
estamos aqui e aranha estava tipo aqui
um time na mão ela subiu ali pra cima
com uma faca kintay a meu ver eu não sei
como é que eu vou matar aqui ó assim
chego é não mexer não não era pra ela
mexe boy faz um caso já olha lá andar
méxico de grande com aquilo não aí é o
próximo salto por cima é outra tira por
ele agora né não chamar alguém aí ela
vai tirar as minhas coisas ela vai
entrar em minha mala não voa daqui pra
cima que os alvos da vida as coisas tive
a minha preta não sujar por engano
estou tentando salvar a mãe dela quer
ciro tenta uma vez encontrei com um
bichinho banda grande também mas este
episódio logo por aí não é nem questão
não pode ser
ela vai comer a esposa toda sai demônio
sol não bate palminha esponja estas
podia ser anti ruído dianteira em
avançar né
ela está atrás dos quatro é que vai
agora atrás de batman não está atrás de
button e eu fui parar mas ela é grande
mas é bom e fininha porto foi o triunfo
que ganha dentro do lille no meio
daquela tá é o supremo não não acho que
não acho que ela ainda está aqui embaixo
do meu deus do céu tá aqui traz ao oeste
quer batalha sobretudo isso como o seu
amigo eu nem sequer quer matar o quinto
partido e eu acho que ela incluiu os
patinhos toda sobre o não consegui ver
porque ela é o fim do quadro meu deus
não pô eu estou a tentar ver o movimento
eu vou tirar esta toda a equipa
tudo paulista
eu acho que ela está aqui meu ex o pai
ai ai tô sentindo depois placas delas
premiadas
aqui não entram bichinhos como ela
entrou que era eu acho que o ritmo
eu ia começar
olha aí conselheira bafana' furou e de
tentarem aproximar eu tenho a minha mala
menina vai encomendar copa eu gritei e
matar bloco logo na hora de subir quem
como é que ela não tá lá ela foi pro
canto como assim
ela entrou dentro o tudo é copiado menor
é só como uma tarefa em estudo está a
estudar até é não perder tempo estudar
até lá não tenho que matar o rio estiver
no chão está tudo bem é só pisar aula
agora é o canadá será que ela vai
começar a levantar voo e vai começar a
subir o teto e vai mal diz o estudo
fala aí